the world marks a somber milestone today
international holocaust remembrance day
in memory of the six million jews who
were killed in nazi occupied germany and
beyond and as that generation who
remembers firsthand the atrocities
dwindles over time there is a renewed
push for education and sensitivity
especially as we see a rise of
anti-semitism attacks and holocaust
denial so we want to welcome gideon
taylor he is president of the claims
conference it's a non-profit advocacy
group for survivors of the holocaust and
their descendants gideon welcome to
quick take
i grew up in new york in the 1980s and
learning about the holocaust was a big
part of history class and also a very
normal part of history class and it was
very much in the culture through
newspaper articles tv reports and movies
but
that's not necessarily the case anymore
is it can you tell us first off how much
do young americans really know about the
holocaust
less and less and as we move further and
further away from the time of the
holocaust
we've seen and surveys that we've
carried out have shown a very alarming
lack of knowledge about the holocaust
lack of awareness
and that's particularly troubling coming
at a time as there are fewer and fewer
political survivors to tell their own
stories in their own words and that's
what's driven us to
really look at all different ways that
we can make sure that the lessons of the
holocaust what happened can be
transmitted to future generations and
particularly to a younger generation
right i know a recent survey found that
half of americans could not name a
single concentration camp gideon based
on that and what you just described what
do you think is the single biggest
contributing factor to this lack of
knowledge and education about the
holocaust
i think there's a lot of reasons i mean
partly it's distance in time
partly
it's fewer survivors
and partly also
i think the way in which
a younger generation learns is very
different from
how it was 5 10 15 years ago and
that is i think is what sort of driven
us to say we need to look for new ways
to reach a generation that's
lacking in knowledge and awareness and
that's what led us to looking at social
media as a critically important tool
to communicate lessons that are
important and relevant not because of
the historical fact or just because of
the struggle fact but because of what
they say about us as human beings and
our society
right so tell us about this social media
campaign that you've launched that
applauds uh people who stand up against
hate what are some of the stories that
you tell and what kind of broader impact
do you hope it will have
so the campaign is hashtag don't be a
bystander
and it is pretty much as the hashtag
says i i think what you have stories
that come from from the holocaust
remarkable stories of people
who were not bystanders and they weren't
bystanders at a time where the risks to
themselves
of of of partaking of of taking sides of
helping a a a jew
were in some cases a penalty of death so
these were people who
gave everything or risked everything in
order to do what was right and i think
the lessons that that carry for us are
as powerful in all of the issues and
challenges we face today as they were
then and that's why we want to use these
voices the voices of holocaust survivors
while we still have holocaust survivors
with us well we still have uh
uh people whose righteous
among the nations people who took those
kind of risks to help people during the
holocaust
how what can be more important than to
take those messages this holocaust day
and to transmit it to a younger
generation through a social media
campaign
through the through the medium that's so
important for communication uh with a
wider population with a younger
population
right it's incredibly powerful but on
social media and uh in the real world
we're more divided than ever right how
do you encourage people to risk
themselves for others in an era where we
can't even get people to take a
life-saving vaccine
i i think a lot of what it is that
people will do
is because of what they see done by
figures that inspire
uh by stories that move
that move them those are the things i
think that shape a lot of our conduct
not being told what to do
or being a
instructed in a classroom to do a b or c
i think what it what leads people to
action is to seek concrete examples and
some of those examples are at home or
friends or peers and sometimes they're
events or people who were at seminal
moments of history and i think that's
why the stories of holocaust survivors
and the stories of rescuers
are so powerful because
uh that's what can influence a person
can make a person say wow
that is what a person did that's
something that i can think about what
does that mean for me it's inspirational
and in in some ways aspirational as well
gideon i want to get your thoughts on
the latest news and there seems like
there's a headline on this every single
day uh a tennessee school board has
voted to remove mouse which is a graphic
novel on the holocaust from its eighth
grade curriculum apparently there are
concerns about offensive themes and
vulgar language how do you sanitize
something like the holocaust
it's very hard to
transmit in a in an effective way
a horror that's beyond comprehension how
can we understand and take
six million jews were killed
staggering beyond our comprehension and
that's why i think over time people have
looked for ways to transmit
and make
real and and make it something that
people can understand to get your hands
around what's incomprehensible and there
were films that people said were
concerned they were concerned about
things like mouse books like mouse and
others that look for innovative ways i
think we always need to be
looking for innovative ways to transmit
a message of something that's so hard to
to educate about and we need to educate
yes in scholarship and and books and
so on but we also need to find ways that
are creative and that address and meet
people where they are because you can't
educate people where you the educator
are or us the adults are you have to
meet people where they are if you want
them to understand
what happened and what is the lesson
that can be taken from it and that i
think is critically important for us i'm
really glad you bring up the importance
of these lessons gideon because
unfortunately we have consistently seen
a raise in hate crimes anti-semitism in
the u.s
i'm curious do you think that education
in our shared history can lessen the
frequency and severity of these events
and how so
i i think you can't do it without it i
think the lessons that we see from hate
crimes um
is is is exactly a lack of understanding
of history and a lack of understanding
of other communities i mean it's those
two gaps that are
what are so often leads to this cancer
in our society of uh of of hatred and
hate speech and our earlier social media
campaign also sort of built around that
it was called it started with words
hashtag it started with words and that
was a previous campaign and the message
there was one
that the holocaust didn't happen
didn't start with death camps and
auschwitz it started with what people
said and how people said it and that's
equally a lesson that is a partner
lesson to the one we talk about don't be
a bystander it started with words is
also a lesson that we hope resonates and
we believe resonates with people think
about what you say because look what it
can lead to and that's what holocaust
survivors and videos said again and
again in that campaign
and
and i think that's something that
resonates with young people and
such such those voices and giving a
megaphone to holocaust survivors so that
public and young people will hear their
voice that's what this campaign's about
well as george santayana said those who
don't know the past are condemned to
repeat it and it's something that uh you
choose to show in different ways gideon
really appreciate your time thank you so
much for joining us gideon taylor of
course talking about the holocaust
remembrance day
you